-Our first guest tonight
is a very
talented actor you know
from movies such as "Whiplash,"
the "Divergent" franchise,
and "Top Gun: Maverick."
You can see him in the limited
series "The Offer,"
which is streaming now
on Paramount+
and also stars in "Spiderhead,"
which begins streaming
on Netflix June 17th.
Let's take a look.
-Mark, I mean, look, man,
I've been on some, some
crazy-ass project teams, right?
But this one --
this one doesn't feel right.
-Jeff, you know, I sympathize,
but only to a point.
Listen, I got to take off my
friendship hat for a second
and remind you your presence
in this facility,
while technically a punishment,
is a privilege, is it not?
You applied for it.
You were approved for it.
You could just as easily be
at state, with the general pop,
then you really would be
playing pitch and catch --
in your case, catch --
with the likes of Rogan.
You don't even want to know
what he did in his last prison.
-Please welcome back to the show
Miles Teller, everybody.
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back to the show, Miles.
I'm so happy you're here.
-That's how we do it.
-You have so many,
so many projects to talk about,
but I want to start --
you had a real honor.
You grew up in South Jersey
and you got to throw out
a first pitch
at a Phillies game.
Were you nervous?
-I was -- I was pretty nervous.
I tried to cancel it
the last minute.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
-Because I was like,
"I've done it before."
It just really adds
like another layer of stress
to the day
because you're doing interviews
and you're --
-Absolutely.
I would say to the week.
I did it exactly one time and I
would never, ever do it again.
[ Laughter ]
-So this was my second time,
but I threw from the rubber,
which, that's a big thing.
-The first time,
did you do front grass?
-No, I did the rubber
both times.
-The rubber's a big deal,
to go from the rubber.
-And the photo they get
[ Cheering and applause ]
is always like --
no, you don't have
[indistinct] neck.
[ Laughter ]
It's just always --
I always think of like
Judd, you know, Apatow's photo
and just the amount of like --
because you're so nervous
and you're trying so hard
to kind of aim the ball.
It's not very flattering, dude.
-It's a face you very rarely
see actual pitchers have.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I want to stress mine is worse
than this, so I'm not --
I'm not judging.
-I noticed you didn't bring
your photo.
-No, I didn't.
[ Laughter ]
Them's the rules.
-It's your show, Seth.
-When you get to host,
you don't bring the photos.
-Just happy to be here.
-I'll tell you
what I didn't get.
So, was the Bobblehead
given out at the game
you threw out the pitch?
-It was, yeah.
-Now, that's pretty cool,
right here.
You got a "Top Gun" Bobblehead.
-That's a much better face.
[ Cheering, ohs, and applause ]
I mean, just the --
just the co-branding.
-I know.
I know.
That was -- That was pretty --
That was pretty sweet.
Like as a diehard baseball fan
and kind of that little bit
of crossover was very nice.
Like there's some real nice
details to it.
And congrats on this movie,
which, you know, so, "Top Gun,"
you finished in 2019
and, you know, I think it's been
well-reported on
that it was -- it was delayed
until people could go back
and see it in theaters.
-Yeah.
Did it feel great knowing you
had this really exciting thing
that people were eventually
going to see
or were you just like
chomping at the bit,
desperate for people to see it?
-I'd done a good amount
of movies beforehand
and so I didn't --
I didn't feel like
I needed this movie
to ensure future work.
[ Laughter ]
But some of the actors in it,
you know, this was such
a big showcase for them
and, if anything,
I really was just bummed
for the -- for the fans
because the fans, we found,
are just like insane.
[ Cheering and applause ]
They're so ravenous
and they've been waiting.
Okay, we got some here.
-Yeah.
I knew I could feel the
"Top Gun" fans in the audience.
[ Laughter ]
Warmed up a little bit.
But no, so, really, I was just,
I was bummed for the fans
and I couldn't wait for them
to see it
because I knew, as you've --
you know, you've seen the movie.
It's just been like --
It's been a rocket, so.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-You were actually --
Again, much has been written
about the fact
that you guys were actually --
I had Jon Hamm here.
He did not go up in the planes.
He did nothing.
-I know.
-But you were in these planes.
-Oh, yeah.
-And was it awful?
[ Laughter ]
-It was --
I'm not signing up to do it --
Even like I was at the Indy 500
and, you know, the Thunderbirds,
who are amazing,
they fly in formation --
everybody wants
to take me up now and fly
and I just --
I'm like, "It's --"
They go, "We can take you up
when you're in Las Vegas,"
and I go, "Honestly, there's not
a place I'd want to go less
[ Laughter ]
than like -- Not Las Vegas,
but I'm saying I would not want
to go up in your jet
and fly in formation
after being in Las Vegas,
is what I'm saying.
-That's a good point, right.
You stay out late.
You're like,
"What am I doing this morning?
Oh, no!"
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
"Oh, I forgot I said yes
to that thing.
That's not going to be good."
-Did you think
you could fly a plane now,
after being up there
with pilots?
I know you weren't doing
the actual flying.
-It depends on who's
in the plane...
-Yeah, that's a good point,
right.
-...you know?
Like if it's by myself
and I had to, I'll bet on it,
but if I had to like,
if it was my wife or, you know,
my dog or my mom or something...
[ Laughter ]
I would -- I don't --
yeah, I wouldn't want that
responsibility, Seth.
-I don't think I would be able
to do it
with my mom in the plane,
just because I think she'd have
a lot of like, "No, no, no!"
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's like, "I did it in a movie,
Mom, relax."
-You just relax!
"You're going too fast!"
[ Laughter ]
-Fanboy, fanboy.
-What was your --
Didn't you have like a --
like an allergic reaction
to a plane or something?
What was the story?
-Yeah, I told you that
in private, Seth.
[ Laughter ]
No, I thought that's what
we were -- Yeah, I --
Yeah, I landed.
We got done.
They're called a sortie,
basically,
when you go up
and you do some stuff.
And so we landed.
I'm just like, "Man,
I'm not feeling too good,"
and I was like getting --
I was really hot and I just
started itching like crazy,
so I get out of the jet
and I'm just covered in hives,
like head to toe.
Instantly, I go to a doctor.
I do like a blood analysis,
this, that, whatever.
I'm in an oatmeal bath at night.
[ Laughter ]
Like I have sensitive skin,
anyway,
[ Laughter ]
truth be told,
like Irish/Scottish skin.
[ Laughter ]
No dyes, no nothing.
-Ideally, no sun.
-Nothing.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-I can get some sun.
-You can get a little sun, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-It's "Top Gun," baby.
[ Laughter and cheering ]
Whoo! So, anyway, so, like
[ Laughter ]
I go to the doctor
and my bloodwork comes back
and I have
flame-retardant pesticides
and jet fuel in my blood.
[ Ohs ]
-Oh, my God.
-That's what I thought,
but then I thought,
[ Laughter ]
"Wait a second.
This is actually kind of cool."
[ Laughter ]
So I go to set the next day
and Tom's like,
"So how did it go, Miles?
What did they find?"
I was like, "Well, Tom,
it turns out
I have jet fuel in my blood."
[ Laughter ]
And without even skipping
a beat, Tom just goes,
"Yeah, I was born with it, kid."
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
-There's your Top Gun.
-Yeah.
So that was like a very Tom
moment for me.
-Now, your director also
directed "Spiderhead," correct?
-Yeah, Joseph Kosinski.
-Which is really cool.
Obviously did a great job
with that.
This is a -- a very different
kind of film.
This is based
on George Saunders' short story,
one I love a great deal.
-Yeah, so it's based on the
George Saunders short story
in The New Yorker,
"Escape from Spiderhead."
It's myself.
It's Chris Hemsworth.
It's Jurnee Smollett.
Joseph Kosinski directing it
and we filmed it during COVID
in Australia.
The movie, basically, is
Chris Hemsworth's character
runs a facility.
He's kind of half hippie,
half mad scientist.
All the inmates in this facility
voluntarily go there,
instead of kind of going
and serving prison time.
They're all criminals.
And we are under
the experimentation
of Chris Hemsworth
and -- and a lot
of different drugs
[ Laughter ]
and some are fun,
some are -- some are terrifying.
-[ Laughs ]
-And so that's kind of
the premise.
How we -- How we deal
with inmates, too,
and how we should deal
with criminals
and, if it's really
about reformation,
then why are we putting them
in a prison system
where they don't --
I don't think they come
out of prison being,
you know, model citizens.
I don't think that's really
what our prison system is doing.
So, there's some
larger themes there.
But, yeah, I mean, that's
kind of the nuts and bolts.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Yeah. It's really cool.
And, like we said,
with the introduction,
you've been so busy.
"The Offer,"
I'm enjoying a great deal.
-Whoo!
-Thank you.
-This is about the making
of "The Godfather"
and it's incredible,
this movie I've seen
so many times,
how little I knew about all the
hurdles leading up to making it.
It must've been such
a cool project.
Going into it,
did you know this backstory?
-Not really. I think I knew
a little bit about
how they didn't want Al Pacino,
but I didn't know
they didn't want
Francis Ford Coppola.
They didn't want Marlon Brando.
[ Laughter ]
-Studio executives
sometimes nail it, yeah.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-And so, it was just, yeah,
there were a lot of obstacles,
but the biggest one
that I realized was the mob.
I mean, the Mafia,
to shoot in New York,
they really did control
all the Teamsters.
They were the Teamsters
in New York, so,
they talk about they would go
into a building
like in Little Italy
or whatever it is.
They'd come out and all
their equipment would be gone.
So you really did kind of have
to have like a handshake
with the Mafia
because they didn't want
"The Godfather" to be made
because they said the Mafia
is a word that's, you know,
keeping Italian American
immigrants down
"and this movie is only going
to make us look like savages.
We're not. We're proud people,"
and et cetera, et cetera.
So, also, in the movie,
the word Mafia doesn't exist
one time.
They took that out of the script
and that was a big a big reason
why they were able
to get it made, actually.
-That's incredible
because you definitely knew
it was about the Mafia,
even without the word in there.
[ Laughter ]
-I know.
-Yeah. They were like,
[ Italian accent ] Don't worry.
I took care of it.
Nobody's going to know."
[ Laughter ]
It's a great show.
You're wonderful in it.
Hey, thanks so much
for making time for us.
-My pleasure.
-I really appreciate it.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Miles Teller, everybody.
The finale of "The Offer"
will be released Thursday
on Paramount+
and "Spiderhead" begins
streaming June 17th on Netflix.
We'll be right back
with Busy Philipps.